じゃあ説明します 今日はダンマパダからの話ですけど
パマーダマヌユンジャンティ
バアラ ドゥンメディノ ジャナアッパマーダんジャ メーダーヴィー ダナング セッタング ワラクカティパマーダマヌユンジ
ャンティ バアラ ドゥンメディノ ジャナアッパマーダんジャ メーダーヴィー ダナング セッタング ワラクカティ
それに続けて次の偈目今日は説明します
マーパマーダマノユンジェタ マーカーマラティサンテワンアッパマトーヒジャヤントー パッポーティヴィプラーン スカンマーパマーダマノユンジェタ
マーカーマラティサンテワンアッパマトーヒジャヤントー パッポーティヴィプラーン スカンそういうことで
これはこの章はこのアッパマーダという言葉に注力しているところで
うーん 大体仏教を理解する場合は
このパマーダアッパマーダというこの二言葉はしっかりと勉強しておかなくてはいけないんですね
まぁ 他人に知ってるぞと言いふらしたければね
やっぱりそのパーリの言葉ぐらいは覚えておけばね
まぁこの人は知ってるんだよと誤解
誤解されて褒められてくる可能性もあります
一応言葉一つ一つ意味をまずね
見てみましょう パマーダーンアヌユンジャンティ
パマーダーンっていうのは
まぁ一応専門的にこれから説明しますが
まぁ一応仏教では否定している
この怠ることというか
怠けることというかね
まぁサボることでもよろしいんですよ
アヌユンジャンティ パマーダという
まぁ日本語では放逸という言葉になってますけどね
まぁ放逸ということにアヌユンジャンティもうかかっている
そればっかりやっているという
それだけを行っている
いわゆる怠ること 怠けること
サボることをね 人生をね
精一杯やっていると アヌユンジャティっていうのは何かこの
まぁ何て言いますか 徹底的にやるというね
自分で進んで行うという場合はアヌユンジャティということなんて言葉なんですね
諦めずやるという それでこの全然諦めることなくこの怠るんですね
バーラー まぁバーラーっていうのは愚か者というね
智慧のない人 ドゥンメーディーノっていうのはまた同じ意味で智慧がないという
メーディーっていうのは智慧がある
ドゥンメーディーっていうのは頭が悪いというね
智慧がない人 ジャナーっていうのは人々
だからバーラードゥンメーディーノっていうのは形容詞でジャナーっていうのは人々
だから あの 頭の悪いというか
智慧のない愚か者たちが怠ることには耽っているんだと
もう徹底的にそれだけは諦めずやってるんだと
怠ること 怠けること で
それだけの意味で 愚か者は怠けるぐらいの意味なんです
二行目はアッパマーダンチャ メーダーウィ ダナン セッタンワ ラッカティ
アッパマーダン それちゅうのは反対の言葉
怠ること いわゆる不放逸
もう励むこと 怠けないこと
それがメーダーウィ 智慧がある人
智慧の人はダナン セッタンワ ラッカティ
ダナンっていうのは財産
セッタンというのはとても優れている
最高なっていう とても優れている
最高なダナン 財産のように
ワというのはのように
ラッカティ 守る それで智慧のある人は最高な宝物を守るような感じで
この不放逸という性格
怠けないということはしっかり守ると
ということは わかりやすく言えば
智慧のある人は怠けないと
愚か者は怠けると 智慧のある人だったら怠けないと
それからただ お釈迦様は次同じことなんですね
ただ戒めを言うんですね
マー パマーダン マヌユンジェーティ
マー やってはいけない
してはいけないという動詞はマー
動詞じゃないんです それは
ただそのまま使う マーという言葉が入ったら
やってはいけないという
やらない方がいいんですと
パマーダン マヌユンジェーティ
怠けることにふけてはならないと
だから同じ言葉上にありましたからね
パマーダン マヌユンジェーティ
だからこちらではパマーダン マヌユンジェーティ
怠ることにふけることはやってはならない
次にマー カーマラティ サンタワン
ちょっと違う言葉が入るんですね
カーマラティっていうのは欲ですね
いわゆる世俗的な欲 ラティも欲でカーマも欲で
ただ欲だけでも意味がよろしいと思いますけど
サンタワンというのはそういうものにも引っかかってはならないと
で 欲にも溺れてはいけないんだと
それで怠ることもしてはいけないし
欲に溺れることもいけないし
アッパマットヒ ジャハヤンと
それで不放逸 怠けることをしないでジャハヤンと
修行する ならば修行する人
ジャハヤンというのは瞑想するという意味でも入りますけど
修行するとね 怠ることしない
で 修行するならばパッポーティ・ヴィプラーン・スカン
で これヴィプラーン・スカンという言葉
ヴィプラーンというのは偉大なるという
まぁ大という意味で いわゆる量がすごく大きいという
だから偉大なる 計りえないほどという
スカン 喜び 幸福 計り知れない幸福にパッポーティ至るでしょう
まぁ至るでしょうではなくて
至るのですというはっきりした言葉なんですね
そこで怠ることなく修行を
修行を頑張るならば 計り知れないほどの幸福に至るでしょうと
至りますと うん で この二つの二十六
二十七のね 意味は だからすごいもう文法的にはものすごい分かりやすい
愚か者は怠ける 智慧のある人は怠けない
二番目は まぁ怠けることにふけてはならない
それから欲のぼれてはならない
で 怠けないで修行する人は
計り知れないほどの幸福を
幸福に至るのですと だから怠けないで修行すると幸せになるんだよと
で これから説明しなくちゃいけないんですけど
説明する前にもう怠けて寝ているんですけど
どうしよう 大体日本でよく見られる現象ですね
あの ブッダの教えは何か言ったら「あ
分かりました」って反対のことするんです
びくっとね 百八十度の反対のことするんです
普通はもう完璧に守らないんですから
まぁ六十パーセントとかね
でもまぁそこそこでもやるでしょ
これは全く不要なんです
怠けたいけないです 「
よく分かります では頑張って怠けるぞ」ってことになりますし 「
寝てはいけない」と言ったら
もう「はい 分かりました」って言って
それからずっと寝ちゃうし
うーん それはまぁ私は知ったことではないんですけど
で 逆に私に訴えるのは私のやり方が悪いんだと
どう言えばいいでしょうか
分からないんですね 昔それ発見して
もしかすると私のこの最後に使う「どうしよう」に惹かれてないでしょうかなと思って
はっきりと「そうではありません」とか 「
その通りです」と もう徹底的に強調して喋ることにもしたんですね
で それはうまく それもよく効き目があったんです
全く前と同じ より明確に逆さまに取ることにしたんです
これはもう直らないんです
私には これ以上どうすることもできない
だから このなかなかいつでも見られることをやってはいけないことは進んでやる
これやってくださいと頼んだら
ものすごく反対して もうそれっきりで口も利かなくなるという
まぁ自由だからいいでしょう
まぁとにかくまぁこれから説明しますけど
この まぁパマーダとアッパマーダ
それはパーリ語でも覚えた方がよろしいんです
パマーダという言葉とアッパマーダという言葉
一応言いますけど パマーダは悪い
アッパマーダはこうお釈迦様は褒めているんです
で 皆様が逆さまに理解したっても
それはまぁ私は知ったことになりませんだからね
一応お釈迦様の場合はパマーダという言葉はもう徹底的に避けなさいと
アッパマーダは実行しなさいと
パマーダっていうのは怠ることです
で これがもう怠ることだったら
もうそれだけではないかと思うかもしれませんだけど
あの もうちょっとあの
意味が複雑ですよ で お釈迦様がこの仏道
修行を通して 生きているものはせっかく生きていたならば
何をするべきかという
もう人間である ありながら
人間であるならばやるべきこと
それをアッパマーダという一言言葉に
もう入れているんです
[笑い]それはこの単語っていうのは便利な道具で
一つの単語を覚えておいて
その単語の中にどういう意味があるでしょうかという
どんどんどんどんゆっくりと勉強しておけば
あの理解はまとめるんですよ
頭は混乱しないんです
ですから まず一つの言葉を覚えておいて
その言葉の意味をゆっくりとゆっくりと勉強していく
勉強していけばいくほど理解が深めていくんです
いくら理解が深めていっても
膨大な理解になっても
自分の頭ではたった一言葉で全部整理する
それがアッパマーダということであると
そのためにある専門用語なんですよ
それ以外でこのパマーダアッパマーダという二言葉は覚えておいた方がやりやすい
例えば日本訳しちゃうと
いきなり意味が小さくなるんですね
その日本語の言葉で表している意味だけに限ってしまうんです
だから訳するのは悪くはないんだけど
それなりのすごい能力ある人でないと訳はできません
で 仏教の理解だけではなくて
自分が訳するその言語の使い方についても
ものすごい徹底的な知識がないと訳できない
ただ単になんとか言葉を選んだだけで
辞書を引いてなんとか選ん言葉を選んだだけで訳したことになりません
それで現代語にしてしまえば
その時人間使っている意味に留まってしまうんですね
で 例えばお釈迦様が自分の悟りの智慧で
もう修行して いろんな悟りを経験して
悟りのうちで世界を見て
人類を観察して 自分の発見したものを一言葉で喋るでしょうし
それでそれは日本訳して怠けろと言っても
それは日本人が怠けると思っている意味とお釈迦様が考えたことというのは決して同じくなるはずがないんですね
そういうことだから まずとりあえず
まず言葉を覚えておく
それからゆっくりとその意味を何なのかと理解していくという方法なんですね
やれるのは それでアッパマーダというのはやってはいけないことで
パマーダアッパマーダっていうのはやるべきことで
パマーダっていうのは決してやってはいけないことで
それで人間で生まれたならばアッパマーダになりなさいと
それでアッパマーダを行うこと
アッパマーダを実践することが
生きている者の唯一がやるべきことなんですよ
それでもっと現代的な表現を使うならば
例えばみんなもう何のために生きるのかと
生きる目的って何なのかと
いろいろ欺瞞疑問があるんです
疑問 そういうなんで生きてるのかという疑問がある人にとっては
元気で生きていられるということもできないし
いつでも何したっても矛盾感じちゃうし
意味がないんではないかとかね
というふうに思ってしまうし
それで生きる目的があるんだぞという人も
結局目的がわかってるわけじゃないんだから
何かバカなことをやって人生終わってしまうし
で そういうことで 生きてるものっていうのはアッパマーダになることモットーにしなくちゃいけない
それがもう生きがいにしなくちゃいけない
それがどうしてもやらなくてはいけないこと
必ずしも行わなくてはいけないことにしておかなくちゃいけないんですね
そうすると それが何なのかと
このアッパマーダというやつは何なのかと聞くと
だったら生きる目的って何なのかとかね
何のために生きているのかとかね
そこら辺は理解しておかなきゃいけないんですよ
そこらで理解して もうなんとか生きるための目的っていうものは発見しなくちゃいけないんですよ
だから その一言葉の意味っていうのは
そう簡単に解説っていうのはね
できるわけじゃないんです
それで今 私は一応仮の解説していますけど
どんどん仮の解説を積み重ねていって
一応いくらか細胞のところで
これは最終的な解説だよと言わなくちゃいけないんですね
今は仮の解説の段階です
段階です 段階ですけど
それで では生きる目的だとすれば
それぞれその人は自分勝手な生きる目的を持っているでしょうね
それぞれの人は自分勝手な生きがいを持っているでしょうね
それがアッパマーダですかと
ある人は例えばもう畑作ることは自分にとって楽しくて生きがいだと
ある人は酪農 牛たちと一緒にいること
これ楽しくてたまらないんだと
これが生きがいだと ある人は旅行することが生きがいだと
いろいろあるでしょうに
そういうことだから それが人間の生き甲斐ですかと
だったらまた把握できなくなるんですね
困ったことになるんですね
何がアッパマーダですかと
そこで生きがいって言っても生きがいだから
これは万人が人間であるならば誰でもやることでなきゃ真理にはならないんです
ある一人の人が酪農で牛買って牛のお世話をすることは最高の幸せだと思っていても
それ自体真理じゃないでしょうね
その人は好きだったら勝手にやればいいということで
だからって人類みんな牛を飼うべきだというと
これはおかしい話で ある人は音楽を作ることやら演奏することは
自分にとっては最高の幸せ
幸福だと思って とってもその人は勝手にやればいいということで
人類みんな同じことをやるべきだという話にはなりませんね
それで真理ということは
この人類みんなやらなくてはいけないこと
か みんなやっていること
どちらなんですね やらずにいられないことというか
必ずやることでなきゃいけません
それからもうまた考えちゃうと
このパマーダとやってはいけないことは
仏教から見ればみんな平気で堂々とやっているんだと
だから我々にはやらずにいられない
いられない状態はパマーダなんです
それの反対にアッパマーダやりなさいと仏様は言っているんです
だからアッパマーダはわからない
しかし 研究してみれば
パマーダの発見はできないわけじゃないんです
パマーダという行為 放逸という行為は
どんな人間もやらずにいられない状態で
必ずやることなんです
それはやらずにはいられない
だから生きる生きているものは呼吸しているんだと言うと
これみんなやってるんですよ
誰か私は嫌やと思って呼吸を止まることはできません
わがままは利かないんですよ
呼吸はやらなくてはいけない
呼吸することは別に何か苦しいかというと
別にどうったことはないんです
もし人が呼吸することさえもすごい困難になってしまうと
それでもその人は呼吸するんです
それでも苦労して頑張って
機械でも道具を使ってでも呼吸するんです
やらずにいられない状態なんです
自分は呼吸困難です 呼吸するのはものすごい苦しいんだと
だから俺がそれをやめたとということは
呼吸困難の病気に悩んでいる人にさえも言えないんですよ
その人もお願いして もう胸に穴を開けてでも
喉に穴を開けてでも あるいはもう鼻から管を入れてでも
あるいはもう何か搬送マシンとかなんとか機械の中に入れてでも呼吸をさせてちょうだいという話なんです
苦しくてもいいんだと
胸に穴を開けてもいいんだと
呼吸はしたいと そういうことで
生きているものがどうしてもやっているということ
呼吸みたいなもんで では呼吸は体のことだからね
その分かりやすいんですね
では我々はね 本当にどうしても
まあ呼吸やらご飯食べることとかね
そんなつまらないことは置いておいて
どんな生命でもね 必ずもやらずにはいられないということは何なのかと
それがまだまだ分かってないかもしれませんだけど
それにお釈迦様がパーマダという言葉を使うんです
どんな生命でも必ずもやるというもの
いくらやめなさいと言ってもやめてはくれない
その性格に それにもパーマダと言うんですね
で そちらには呼吸とかね
ご飯食べるとか そんなものは入りませんよ
そんなのも体のことでね
歩く 座るとかそういうのは入りません
そんなのは必ずやらなくちゃいけないっていうことでもないし
まあ別にどうったことはない
一応まあ心のことなんですけどね
それでそれどうやって発見するかというと
まあ仏教的なやり方っていうのは
あの あまり人気はないんだけど
このやり方はね どんな生命もやることであるならば
私もやっているでしょうと
だから 人のことは分かりませんだから
自分が何をやっている何者かと自分を徹底的に調べる
それで出てくる答えは他の人々にも適しているんでしょうかとひょっと見たら
見事にみんなも同じことやっていると発見できる
それでそれがその言葉の意味になるんです
これが仏教的なやり方なんですけど
世間はそれは否定するんですね
もう他人のことを研究する
私のことはもうそれは完璧だから放っておいてくださいと
だからよくみんな世の中の
世の中を 何て言いますか
世直しのために 世の世の世の中を整理してあげるために一生懸命
だからどんな説教を聞いても
どんな思想家の話を聞いても
どんな評論家の言葉を聞いても
世間に対してみんな説教
説戒というか 説教しているんですね
人の問題について語る
これは世間のやり方で
仏教ではそれはもう使わないんです
やってはいけないんだと
わかるわけもないんだと
自分自身でも何も研究していないにも関わらず
ちょっと水持ってきますから
人のことをわかるわけじゃないんだと
とにかく仏教的なやり方っていうのは
自分が何者かと 私自身が絶対やらずにいられない生き方って何なのかと
それを見るんですよ それで発見するものが答えなんです
それが何の答えかというと
パマーダの答えなんです
まだまだアッパマーダわかってないんです
順番で言えば 次に釈迦さんの言葉を聞く
釈迦さんが言うんですね
パマーダはダメですよと
だから自分が呼吸するのごとく絶対やりたくなってなってやっていることに対して
釈迦様はこれはダメだと
あんた不幸になるんだと
今も不幸でしょうと だから計り知れない幸福になりたければ
パマーダではなくてアッパマーダになりなさいと
アッパマーダになりなさいと言っても
それはまだパマーダがやっと発見した人がね
アッパマーダになるなんてわかるわけないでしょうよ
そこで引き算で行動するんです
今どうしてもやっていることはもう発見しているんだから
それは一つ一つ引いてみる
それで引き算で行為をいろいろ引いて引いてみるところで
じわじわとアッパマーダの世界が成り立つんですよ
そこでアッパマーダの世界が成り立ったところで
そちらにあるのは完全な悟りなんです
解脱なんです 究極な幸福なんです
そういうわけで 私たちはもうパマーダもわかってないところにいるんですよ
ましてやアッパマーダ説法してやるぞ
他人にはとかね 思ってもパマーダもわかってない状態にいるんです
だからそんな今説明したやり方でパマーダを発見してアッパマーダへ至る
というやり方しかないんです
そこはもうだから一応仏教のやり方はそういうやり方だとでも理解してください
やってもやらなくてもどうでもいいんです
論理的にこの物事を理解していると
私は楽なんですよ ごく普通にみんなとね
仲良く挨拶することでも
話すことでもいくらか楽なんですよ
もう話もできんだから
もう阿鼻叫びで無茶苦茶で
何やってるかとさっぱりだからもうもうもう本当にもういろいろ困っているところ結構あるんですね
人間として付き合うことはできなくて
あ やべえと 逃げろという気持ちにいつでもなるんです
[笑い]これちょっと理性はちょっとのところじゃないんで
じゃあちょっとっていうことにしましょう
この理性にかけてるんですね
だからそこら辺はこの
まあこういう考え方もあるんだよと理解ぐらいしておいた方が便利なんですよ
それから人と付き合いできるんですよ
例えば皆様方 イスラム教を信じなくても
イスラム教の人々のやり方は何なのかと知っておけば
たまたまそういう人とも知り合いになったならば
その人と付き合うことはできるようになるんですよ
絶対理解してやらないんだと思っちゃうと
もう付き合うことできないんですよ
だから日本でよく見られる思考っていうのは
例えばイスラム教の人々は豚肉食べないんだと話を聞いちゃうと
よし いいこと教えてもらったと
で その人を家に呼んで
もうあんたイスラム教だから今日はあの豚肉祝祭で全部料理作りましたよと
と言っちゃうんです 必ず作るんですよ
もうもう 味噌汁からもうもうデザートにまで登場するんです
なぜかって だってイスラム教でしょうと
だから本当はイスラム教だから豚っていう名前さえも聞きたくない
名前言っただけでも地獄に落ちる
そういう人々は思ってるんです
そこはどうやって理解するかというと
やっぱりイスラム教の人が来たら豚肉は作るべきだという
このあびこびの思考がよく見られるんですね
そうすると付き合いは成り立たない
だからこの まあとりあえず理解するということが大事なんですね
やるかやらないか それはまあ後の話でね
まあ自分で嫌だったらやらなくてもいいんですよ
しかし理解はすると そういう理解しただけでも
結構人間関係はうまくいくんです
そういうことだから この今の時点で
ではパマーダの理解は仏教でどのようにやるかというと
まず定義 このパマーダっていうのは必ずも生きているものがやることです
やらずに やらずにですね
やらずにいられない行為
それがパマーダですと
それが何でしょうかと
次に考える 何でしょうかと言ったって
世の中の人間研究することできるんだから
自分自身も一人前のしっかりした生きているものだから
自分も必ずも同じことをやらずにいられないことをやっているはずなんですね
それが何なのか 自分やっていることを観察する
ああ こういうことかと分かったところでブッダの話を聞く
なぜブッダがこのパマーダやめなさいと
それは苦しみの元だと
アッパマーダになりなさいと
計り知れない幸福になるんだよと
言ってもし なりなさいとはアッパマーダは何なのかとわからないでしょうに
しかし お釈迦様は見事にパマーダに対してアッパマーダという言葉を使うんですよ
法律に対して不法律 老婆に対してアローバ
ドーサに対してアドーサ
これがお釈迦様の智慧の大発見なんです
でも仏教は普通に勉強している人は
なんだこれ 貪瞋痴 不貪不瞋不痴と
わけれませんと そんなことは言われません
なぜならば お釈迦様はこの言葉一つ一つ明確に考えて選んでいるんですからね
時々私は言いますよ 怒りに怒りは良くない
その代わりに慈しみ 人に親切にすることはいいことだと
そうするとわかりやすい
わかりやすいでしょうね
人のことを怒らないで
人のことに人に対して親切にしましょうと
でもわかりやすいかもしれませんけど
意味が完璧じゃないんです
欲張らないでどうしますかね
むさぼりという良くないことがあるでしょ
貪とむさぼりで訳しますけど
それで反対をお釈迦様は不貪と言うんですね
むさぼりがない これは何なのかと
それで私はわかりやすくみんなに助けてあげることや
お布施する 寄付することはお布施することやとかね
そういう風に言っちゃいますけど
ああそうかと簡単にわかりますよ
しかし それが正しみじゃないんです
正しみは不貪なんです
それでこのアッパマーダで
その論理的なところを今説明しているんです
アッパマーダを置いておいて
アッパマーダ否定形の言葉だから
肯定形のパマーダ すべての人間はパマーダはやっている
それしかやってない それで全ての人間は放っておいて
人間のことを放っておいて
自分のことにする 自分もやってるんだから
それで自分がどうしてもやらせて入れない状態でやることは全部まとめて
それが放逸にする それが放逸ですよと
それで初めて釈尊の言葉を聞かなくては
それで釈尊はアッパマーダというわからない概念を提供するんですね
それでアッパマーダっていうのはパマーダがない状態だから
この人はプラスの 何て言いますか
たくさん持っているでしょうに
それは一つ一つ引くんです
引いていくとアッパマーダなんです
だからアッパマーダで特別な言葉は使わないんです
ただ引き算で十分です
それで我々はやっていること
一つ一つ で それっきりやらないということにしているんですね
それでやってみればみるほど幸福になるはずなんです
必ずもなるとお釈迦様はおっしゃっているんです
引いていくと 足していく時ではなくて
そこで引いていくと引いていくとどんどんもうやがて引くものがなくなっちゃうんです
それが悟りという解脱という領域なんです
何を引くんでしょうか
引くもの何もないんだと
その状態にアッパマーダと言うんです
アッパマーダは完成した状態
そこでこの過程にも一応アッパマーダを実践しているんだというんです
この引いてみる生活に生活を実践する過程にはアッパマーダと言う
でも本格的なアッパマーダというわけでもありません
今日 そういうやり方なんです
それしか具体的な論理的な普遍的なやり方は存在しない
置き換え論理ではないんです
何かのために何かを置き換えるとかね
この置き換えることは世の中でよく言いますけどね
置き換える生き方 人生つまらないんだったら
もっと面白い趣味でも探しなさいよとかね
それは置き換えなんですね
家にいると喧嘩するんだったら
できるだけ外でこの生活してみなさいとかね
友達でも作って どこかのクラブでも入って
そこら辺で遊んでみてみなさいという
置き換え論理なんでしょ
置き換え論理では正しくないんですよ
成長はないんです 家にいると必ず喧嘩する
例えば子供が家に来たとたん喧嘩すると
子供はアドバイス受ける
私はちょっと家に行ったらすぐ親と喧嘩するんだ
どうすればいいかと だったらお前塾やら他のアッチコッチところ行きなさいよと
寝る時間になったら家に戻りなさいよと
それでその子はちゃんとそれを実行する
それで心が成長するかと
あの状態はそのままなんです
親と仲良くする方法はまだまだ習ってないんです
大人になっても 置き換え論理で逃げただけ
だから置き換え論理っていうのは答えじゃないんです
このサブスティテュート
例えば麻薬 タバコ そういうものに依存している人は
やめたければ何かサブスティテュートという何か与えなくちゃいけないんですね
代わりの何か それで弱い状態そのままなんですよ
世の中に存在しているのはこの置き換え方法ですよ
この置き換え方法を教えないんだから
仏教 ブッダの教えに対しては人気はないんです
それで日本で人気ある仏教も揺られますね
みんなもう徹底的に置き換え論理で頑張っているんです
題目を唱えれば全ては解決すると
このお祈りすればもう全て十分だと
そこで何か単純なことを一つ教えてあげる
これに持ちなさいと それをしがみついて
それに忙しくてうまくいかないです
で 何のことも成長しないんですね
例えば末期になって癌になって苦しんでいる
やっぱり死ぬのは怖い
死にたくはない それで天国の阿弥陀様の概念を叩いて
置き換えてもらう でも死ぬのは怖いのそのままなんです
何の成長もなく死ぬんです
で それは宗教的になってくるとちょっと問題もありますからね
だからあまり一人で考えるときは
私は前に言った例でいいんですよ
家にいるといつでもお父さんお母さんと喧嘩する子供を子供にアドバイスする
お前できるだけ家にいる時間を減らしてくださいと
ということで その子は外で一日いろんなことをやって遊び
いいことか悪いことどっちでもいいんですけど
パチンコやるかゲームセンターで遊ぶか
それでもよろしいし あるいはいろんな塾に行って
いろんなところでいろんな
まあもう何て言いますか
稽古事をしたりとかね
そういうことで12時まで過ごすたとどっちでもいいんですけど
家にいる時間をもう極力減らす
そこで朝起きたら即６時にまた出て行く
どこかの稽古やら運動やら何とかってとかね
[笑い]それで例えばいいことをするならば
どうせその子はそれなりに社会で成功するでしょう
朝六時 もう一時間ぐらいスポーツやって
そのままどこかの塾に行って
そのままもう学校やら勉強するところに行って
そのままなんとか何とかいて
それでまた十二時になってくると家に戻ると
戻ってもサッと寝て また六時にまた出かけると
いうことで 親と顔を合わせる時間はゼロ
で 喧嘩にはならない それでうまくいったと
一度も 今十五年も経ってますけど
あれから一度も親と喧嘩したことはないのか
あれ成長してますかね
成長してないんです 置き換えただけ
それでこの置き換え論理は
世の中にあるんだからといって
仏教は認めます 別にそれなりの結果は論理的なものを喋るんだから
それぐらいの結果だよと
答えではありませんと
そういうわけで 仏教はこの悪いことはポジティブ
肯定系で言って 理想とするものは全部否定形で使ってるんです
その文の中で この単語の言葉の選び方にもものすごい違いがあるんです
ただ お釈迦様は私みたいに単語能力はえらい乏しかったとかね
そういうことじゃないんです
私はあまり単語は知りませんだから
もうほんのわずかな単語の中でずっとベラベラ喋ってるんです
そのようなお釈迦様もちょっとした単語しか知らなかった
そんなわけじゃない たくさん言語をもうすごく習っていたし
もう単語の問題なかったんで
とにかく しかし あえて選ぶというね
そういうこの論理的な言葉があって単語を選ぶんですね
否定形の この慈悲喜捨という四つ以外はほとんど
まあ慈悲喜捨とパンニャー
智慧とね いくつかしかないんですよ
ポジティブ 肯定的な単語っていうのは
全部この引き算的な言葉で言うんですよ
なんで引き算で言うかというと
それが具体的なんですよ
自分の手でつかめるんですよ
この得体知れない いまだ経験していない理想的な観念的な概念よりは
この引き算の概念は理解しやすいんですよ
具体的なんです だからきっちりと実行
実践できます 自分の持ってるものから引けばいいんだから
捨てればいいんだから
そういう話し方ですから
仏教では形而上学は成り立たない
宗教は明らかに形而上学ですね
人間には到底も何もできないものを喋る
で 人間がそれに妄想する
妄想してあるの如く信じ込む
お釈迦様が言う 妄想しててあんた知ってるものから妄想するんだと
だからどうったことないんだと
私たちは天国を妄想しても
人間毎日経験してる世界から妄想するんだから同じものなんですよ
あのレゴを持っていろんな何を組み立てても
自分持ってるレゴでしか組み立てられないんです
レゴのブロックを三百個持っている子は
それで組み立てて組み立ていろんなものを作るかもしれませんだけど
何を作るにしたっても
あの三百個しか使えないんです
そういうことだから 形而上学的な思考っていうのは何のこともないってことになっちゃうし
仏教ではまあない ブッダの教えでは
はい  そんな論理過程をちょっと覚えておいてください
えーと パマーダ アパマーダ理解するときでも
ローバ アローバ理解するときでも
ドーサ アドーサ いわゆる怒りと怒りのない状態
で モーハ アモーハ だから日本語になってくると痴ですね
あの貪瞋痴のね あの 知と書くんですけど
あれは無知の 無知ではなくて
あの どうやって書くんです？やま
あの 何て言うんでしょう
山井だれに知  確知の知ですね
山井だ  山井だれの中に知る
知るっていうこと だからこれは知恵がないっていうことなんですね
とにかく仏教でははっきりと無我というね
言葉があります それはポジティブ系
この漢字見ても結局は否定
否定形なんですよ しかし
それがあまり仏教使わなくて
無我という肯定形の言葉を使って
知恵に無我というんです
無我がない状態 そういう風にこの
歴算的な思考は であります
なぜ歴算的かというと
それが具体的なんです
足し算思考は具体的じゃないんです
観念的なんです 妄想 形而上的なんです
それで我々の生き方は見てください
我々はずっと足し算的な生き方をしているんです
何考えたって何か足すことしか考えないんです
だから無知で観念的で具体性っていうのはまるっきりなくて
頭の中の妄想で生きているんです
それが自分の生き方で研究すればわかりやすい
自分がいつでも何か足し算的に考えているのではないかと
それほど難しくないんですね
もうちょっと朝1時間ぐらい運動でもしましょう
何のため？なんかまあ一応健康になるのではないかと
健康を足すですよ まあ体力は付くんじゃないか
それ足すでしょ 足すなんですね
今日はせっかく休みだから
そこら辺の公園にでも遊びに行きましょうかと
足すなんです ちょっと楽しんでみようと
今日1日って楽しみを足す
それで家に帰って疲れた
じゃあテレビでも見よう
足すなんです それ友達が来る
その人はその番組はものすごい嫌い
じゃあ何かゲームカードでもやりましょう
それで足すんです 私たちには足す思考しかないんですよ
これにはパマーラというんです
だから必ずしも嫌らすにいらない状態でしょ
パマーラ  パマーラ それパマーラではないです
いつでも情報に目を開けておく
何か新しい変わったことないのかと
それ全部足すんです 服のデザインやら色やら色々変化する
すぐその変化に敏感に気づいて足すんです
流行に遅れてはならんと
だから足す思考で生きてるっていうことは
我々は 1 秒も忘れることはしない
だから怠けるという単語はそれほどふさわしくないんです
惰性に近いですね 惰性
惰性には近いです で あの惰性にも近いんですけど
これでアクティブか活発かそうでないかという概念を入れてみると
惰性はほとんど活発的という風にもならんですよ
でもパマーラでない人は結構活発ですよ
パマーラであればあるほどかなり活発なんです
だから即席の怠けという言葉も使いづらいし
ややこしいんですよ パーリ語の単語を意訳するっていうのは
本能に駆り立てられてる
ん？ 本能に駆り立てられてる
でも単語は何ですかね
何かせずにいられない
落ち着きがない  それも一部的な状況でしょ
思考してるとか 妄想してるってことですね
それも一部の仕事でしょ
ごく一般的な仕事は全て 24時間我々はもう足し算で生きてますよ
だから私は別に言ったら単語がないんだということなんです
いくら殺したって意味がないんですよ
パマーラを見事に置き換える単語は存在しないんです
だからパーリ語の言葉でまず覚えておいて
覚えたからといってわかったわけじゃないんです
それでゆっくりと経験の中から理解していく
まあなんとなく似ている単語はもうたくさんありますよ
例えば伝統的には放逸という言葉があるでしょうし
悪くないんだけど 放逸っていうのはなんかやるべきことをやってないような意味なんですけどね
まあでも本人はそう感じないでしょうね
結構やりたい放題っていうイメージはありますかね
うん ああ そうですね やりたい放題イメージだったら結構結構違うんですね
じっとしていられない
何かせずにはいられないということもつまりよろしいでしょうか
だから前落ち着かないということを言ったでしょ
そういう  マシューさんの言ったやりたい放題が一番近い
やりたい放題ということはすごく近いんです
だからとりあえずその言葉でやりましょう
やりたい放題の生き方
そうすると誰でもそれ好きでしょうね
ん？ なすがままは？なすがままとか思いのままに振る舞う
思いのままはいいんだけど
なすがままっていうのはちょっと違うんじゃないですか
欲しいままに振る舞う
もういいですか？ まあ一応そこら辺なんで
やりたい放題とかね 欲しいままに
思うがままにというね
なすがままにはちょっと
ちょっとわからないな
なんかニュアンスが違うなという感じがしますけどね
そんなあたりですよ 意味は
それで私は何者かと自分のことを聞いてみると
やっぱりやりたい放題でやりたいでしょうね
それで世間と関わりがあるんだから
ただやれないだけのことで
それで私の生き方何なのかというと
世間と対立してどこまでやりたい放題やれるかってことなんです
それが自分なんです 世間はもう我々もう世間の中で生きてなくちゃいけないんだから
あなたがやりたい放題ことをやってくださいっていうことにはなりませんし
だから世間の条件の中で我々は必死で踏ん張っちゃうんですね
自分がやりたい放題で生きているために
それの成功の度合いは自分なんです
だから結局私は何者かと
自分のパマーダをどこまでやっているかということなんです
そこでわかりやすいんですよ
パマーダが強烈であればあるほど
俗世間では成功者と言うんです
だから 人にやりたい放題のことをできればできるほど
その人は成功しているんですよ
やりたいことがあるのに一つもできないという場合はね
かなりもう成功者じゃないでしょうに
悔しいでしょうに そういうことだから
人間にいくら言ってもパマーダやめなさいと
やめるわけにはないわけはないんですよ
人間の頭でどう考えたっても
パマーダ的な生き方で自分を何て言いますか
構成されますから パマーダが重くたくさん実行できれば成功者なんですね
それでみんな人生成功したと思ってるでしょうに
そういうわけだから パマーダ以外はね
わかると言ったら それは全くの根拠のない嘘ですよ
アッパマーダはわからないんです
パマーダだったらわかるんです
頑張ればわかるんです
しかし 今まで私がした説明さえも普段はしないはずなんです
普段は人間のよく勉強して
よく仕事して よく頑張って成功するものではないかとかね
マイホームでも作って
幸せな家庭を築いて それが人に迷惑
他人様に迷惑をかけないで生きることではないかと堂々と言ってるでしょうに
それだけであって これが客観的な分析っていうことは誰もしない
この生き方 だから今まで説明してた定義も解説も世間には存在しない
そこでパマーダっていうのは
我々の本能に基づいて
本能の要求に応じてやりたい放題やるということなんです
そこでやりたい放題やりたいんだけど
まあ事実上はできませんね
そこでいくらかどこかで
ここまでということが成り立つんですよ
そこに自分個人の成功したところやと名付けちゃうんですよ
それが他人と比べるんですね
私はここまでなんですけど
あの人はあそこまで行ってるんだと
それで成功しているかないか
ごちゃごちゃいろんなことを世間で言ってるんですよ
それでまたさらに悩むんですよ
より成功しなくちゃいけないんだとか
だから やりたい放題ほとんどできない人は
まあ不幸な人間 失敗さん
いろいろ言われますよ
言われるなら その人はさらに精神的に落ち込んじゃって
精神的に病気になってしまうんです
犯罪者にもなる 引っ込み思案になる
やっとこの人成功したっていうのも
その馬鹿が比べるんだからね
隣の人の成功と そうするとまたなんか納得いかなくなっちゃう
で そこが我々の生き方で
どんな人でもやってます
やってない人はいません
これがパマーダという状況なんです
そこまで一応わかったとして
次のステップに行かなくちゃいけない
まあわかったことに私はします
強引に もう時間もないんだから
よくわかりましたでしょう
だから だったら次のステップに進まなくちゃいけない
[咳]